et notre invité pour cette semaine
spéciale l'agriculture c'est christiane
lambert bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous présidente de la sns
vous êtes avec nous pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représentée par stéphane bern est mon
jour stéphane bonjour j'ai un petit
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france
un mot d'abord christiane lambert
puisque il y a un nom on était au salon
de l'agriculture qui a dû fermer ses
portes un jour plus tôt pour cause de
crise sanitaire
cette année le salon ouvrira pas ses
portes c'est un rendez vous auquel les
français sont attachés c'est un rendez
vous auquel les agriculteurs sont
attachés est ce que c'est une décision
difficile pour vous ça a été une
décision très difficile un crève coeur
une décision que nous avons prise en
septembre parce qu'il faut anticiper vu
le nombre d'exposants c'est le salon le
plus fréquenté de france se témoignent
de l'attachement des français
l'agriculture et pour nous c'est un
moment de dialogue extrêmement important
sur l'évolution de notre métier
l'alimentation l'environnement nos
pratiques et c'est tout ce que les
français attendent de nous alors ça
revêt une une relief particulier avec la
crise qu vide et la souveraineté
alimentaire la capacité à s'alimenter on
n'a pas eu de pénurie malgré les
craintes des uns des autres et les
français en redécouvert leur agriculture
leur alimentation nous avons des
hommages important il ya toujours des
attentes c'est normal et on est prêts à
dialoguer avec tout le monde mais ils
vont être privés de salon c'est dommage
par contre il ya beaucoup d'événements
qui s'organisent en région à paris
lesquels alors à l'heure en août france
j'ai vu que le président de région avait
engagé énormément de visites
d'exploitations les chambres
d'agriculture ont invité à visiter les
exploitations des départements viennent
sur paris la corrèze sera là la semaine
prochaine beaucoup de départements vont
venir faire des événements
et puis nous nous organisons une semaine
internationale de l'agriculture 20 le
sénégal en racer du salon organise et
nous nous ferons beaucoup d'activités du
14 au 23 mai avec notamment un grand
colloque international où nous avons
évité le présent de la république qui
sera présent justement sur le thème de
la souveraineté alimentaire est sûrs à
lyon alors qui aura lieu à paris mais en
digital pour être sûr de sécuriser parce
qu'on ne sais pas qu'est-ce qui se
passera au moins deux mais ça permettra
énormément de public de se connecter et
de suivre ce qui fait ce sera un
rayonnant très important est que malgré
l'absence de salon les français peuvent
rencontrer leurs agriculteurs et se
tenir au courant bien sûr dialoguer et
les portes sont ouvertes et nous sommes
des gens de dialogue venez nous voir on
va parler de l'actualité et on va parler
de lyon le maire de lyon a décidé
d'instaurer lé menu unique sans viande
qu'est ce que est ce que pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que les agriculteurs se
mobilisent contre cette décision
est ce que c'est vraiment un combat qui
mérite une mobilisation forte
d'abord c'est une décision arbitraire
sans consultation
secundo pourquoi seulement la ville de
lyon a des problèmes pour assurer les
gestes barrières et l'alimentation des
enfants
lille ne le décide pas paris marseille
nantes ne le décide pas donc il ya
vraiment beaucoup d'idéologie derrière
c'est évident ça faisait partie du
programme l'utilisation pour moi alors
nous défendons-nous la production de
lait en france
nous défendons l'alimentation avec de la
viande les recommandations du plan
national nutrition santé préconise la
consommation de viande ni même un décret
du 9 septembre 2011 qui encadrent
qu'est-ce qu'il faut servir dans les
cantines des enfants par rapport à les
la croissance des enfants leurs besoins
nutritionnels donc tout ceci est
encadrée je pense que c'est pour ça que
monsieur de normandie a décidé de saisir
le préfet nous avait écoutés on va voir
si le décret qui encadre ce qu'on doit
donner à manger aux enfants ou pas salut
c'est pas un combat d'arrière-garde
moins je sais qu'il ya de plus en plus
de gens qui veulent manger végétarien et
je respecte mais l'imposer c'est pas
normal
si à leur choix oui genre colons l'année
dernière quand il était encore en tout
cas quand même lui avait lui même pris
des menus des menus végétariens ni et je
les jeux les découverts sur twitter
dimanche après midi
je n'y avais pas la laisser passer je
n'avais pas vu passer oui mais et si
vous l'aviez vu passer à l'époque vous
aurez à gérer de la même façon mais bien
sûr j'ai fait moi je suis le moins je
fais pas de politique je regarde je
défends les producteurs je défends la
façon dont nous produisons la viande en
france qui n'a rien à voir avec les
filles de loth que yann arthus-bertrand
a montré dans son hymne dans son film
legacy où il a essayé de faire penser
que c'était l'élevage à la française
c'est faux et je dis aussi que l'élevage
en france
énormément de vertus la viande que nous
consommons nous allons bon
besoin que dit le plan national
nutrition santé aussi que les femmes de
plus de 50 ans je suis dans cette
catégorie en ont besoin aussi pour leur
équilibre alimentaire dans la viande il
ya des protéines qu'on ne trouve pas
dans l'alimentation végétale il a aussi
des acides aminés il a le zinc il ya le
faire il ya la vitamine b12 la fameuse
vitamine b12 la béquille alimentaire
dont ont besoin les végétariens élévé
gamme il faut écouter les médecins sur
ces sujets là et franchement 6 pour
certains enfants le repas de midi
c'est le seul repas où ils mangent de la
viande et j'ai souvenir au moment du
confinement
quand il avait été décidé de mettre des
v non quand la loi alimentation a décidé
mettre des repas végétariens
certains prestataires de renault ont
envoyé un flyer aux parents dans le
cartable des enfants disant votre enfant
n'a pas mangé de viande à midi veilleux
lui donner une alimentation équilibrée
avec des protéines ce soir c'est
révélateur
justement il ya des parents qui veulent
saisir la justice suite à celle des
styles ans ce que vous les encourager
alors il y avait hier avec les
agriculteurs qui ont manifesté à lyon
des parents d'élèves qui ne sont pas du
tout d'accord avec cette décision
visiblement ça a été pris de façon
autoritaire et sans consultation donc
c'est vraiment d'idéologie et du
dogmatisme et c'est ça qui est pas
acceptable
donc pas de sapin de noël pas de tour de
france pas de viande à la cantine c'est
quoi le prochain truc
donc on voit ya pas de raisons
sanitaires c'est vraiment de l'idéologie
à un mot quand même pour parce que je
n'ai la rapidité c'est une chose mais
comment les autres villes y arrive et
pas lyon c'est quand même un sultan
aussi pour les cuisiniers et cantinière
de la ville de lyon je pense qu'ils
doivent se dire pourquoi nous et
pourquoi les autres rêvez pas nous un
mot sur julien normandie qui vous
soutient ça on l'a dit barbara pont
pilier laisse pas sur cette ligne
elle regrette qu'on retombe dans un
débat préhistorique je cite des clichés
éculés du type l'alimentation
végétarienne serait une alimentation
déséquilibrée
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez madame
pompe il ya besoin de se démarquer
c'est classique je crois qu'elle a tort
de l'aborder ainsi nous ne sommes pas
contre l'alimentation à partir de
légumineuses et de protéines végétales
d'ailleurs dans ma région est une
association qui s'appelle légaux à
l'ouest légumineuses de l'ouest ça
signifie justement pour faire ses
produits dans france protéines végétales
aujourd'hui ils sont importés
majoritairement et on va d'ailleurs les
problèmes qu'il peut y avoir et les
graines de sésame et le rapport du
sénateur du plomb la semaine dernière
moi je fais la différence entre le libre
choix et ce qui est imposé de façon
autoritaire face ce côté voilà ce que
vous devez faire mesdames et messieurs
si vous voulez être responsable c'est
insupportable on nous dit ce qu'il faut
manger comment il faut se déplacer etc
non l'incitation l'information des
consommateurs oui les obligations et les
injonctions
non l'autre actualité c'est emmanuel
macron le président de la république qui
se rend en côte d'or aujourd'hui à la
rencontre des agriculteurs qu'est ce que
vous attendez du chef de l'état le chef
de l'état va sur le thème de
l'alimentation et surtout sur le thème
du respect là l'eau alimentation ou qui
a été son cheval de bataille dès son
arrivée à l'elysée
force est de constater que ça ne marche
pas comme prévu il y à des avancées dans
certains domaines en production laitière
mais il ya beaucoup de secteurs où ça ne
marche pas et puis il ya quand même un
exemple on met en bobine ça ne marche
pas mais ça ne marche pas globalement on
va avoir cette année une déflation
encore des baisses de prix alors que les
négociations en production les centrales
d'achat l'agriculture se passe mal ça
serait la dépression au siècle il met en
avant ce qu'ils font bien je lisais hier
soir la communication l'un d'entre eux
il dit je paye les oeufs différenciés
selon qu'ils sont au sol ou ceux qui
sont en cage
ok ça ça fait trois ans cinq ans que ça
dure voilà la hausse de prix de mal à
l'ordinateur à matières premières quand
le blé ou le soja augmente pour
l'alimentation animale ça a un impact
énorme en ce soit pour les poules et les
poules pondeuses ou les ports s'il n'y a
pas au bout une répercussion sur les
prix de vente ou s'ils ne comprennent
pas leurs marges
ça ne marche pas nous disent que ça n'a
jamais été aussi tendues que cette année
scolaire confirmé dans les négociations
avec les les centrales la grande distrib
à ce qu'il joue un double jeu
il nous allons alors que la loi gunhild
main alors qu'il ya la loi et galets et
ils se font les grands défenseurs du
pouvoir d'achat mais qu'est ce qu'il y
avait dans les colonnes de ouest france
vendredi dernier
carrefour a fait une année historique
plus 7,8 pour cent du chiffre d'affaires
chiffre d'affaires + 16,4 pour cent de
résultats vous rendez compte chiffre
d'affaires résultat à sauviac les marges
sont super confortable et donc ça veut
dire qu'ils se moquent totalement il ya
un discours de façade alors carrefour en
plus bénéficier copieusement des aides
d'état
quand fâché de voir la fermeture des
commerces non alimentaires
il a mis beaucoup de ses salariés
je partiel pour profiter des aides
d'état et 3 mais après il est prêt à
aller s'offrir accouche l'arlem et
pâques avec carrefour
c'est le problème avec d'autres y
assurent en gros doutes quant aux mains
des screaming leclerc a été condamné il
ya un an et demi
111 millions d'euros d'amendé par la
dgccrf
lassé intermarché qui vient d'écoper de
150 millions d'euros d'amendé 1 % de son
chiffre d'affaires ça veut dire qu'il ya
de plus en plus de contrôles qui
constate de plus en plus anomalies mais
ça veut dire aussi que cette grande loi
légalise mais ne fonctionne pas alors
elle ne fonctionne pas comme elle
devrait fonctionner mais moi je suis
attaché à ce qu'elle respecte ce qu'elle
doit améliorer le député grégory besson
moreau a fait un rapport parlementaire
dans lequel il a fait un certain nombre
de constats notamment que les
distributeurs passe par des plateformes
à l'étranger au luxembourg en belgique
pour contourner la loi française c'est
là-dessus qu'intermarché a été rattrapé
par la patrouille et bienfaisant sorte
de reprendre un certain nombre de
propositions du député grégory besson
moreau pour rendre cette loi plus
opérante
les distributeurs sont imaginatifs ya
tellement de cas euros en jeu mais moi
ce que je vois c'est que pour sortir de
dix ans de baisse des prix 1 milliard
d'euros détruits chaque année il se
détruisent eux-mêmes ils se font une
chasse fratrie concurrence entre la
brune ferrand senteurs pour tous est une
guerre des prix qui traduit une guerre
de part de marché les trois plus gros
veulent faire tomber les trois plus
petits pour les reprendre
c'est clair dans ça sent encore une
concentration et ça nous n'en voulons
pas donc nous nous sommes attachés à ce
que les dispositifs de la loi qui ont
été votées par la représentation
nationale s'applique que ceux qui
trichent soient sanctionnés et s'il ya
encore non respect à l'origine quand
même c'était rééquilibrer pour leurs
revenus les agriculteurs
c'est ce à l'origine les états généraux
et ça va distribuer mais ça n'a pas tenu
ses promesses mais les distributeurs se
sont servi copieusement l'année dernière
avec le confinement
quand les restaurants sont fermés les
gens achètent leur alimentation ou plus
en grande surface + 6 % le chiffre
d'affaires donc ils ont marge est
copieusement
ils ont eu des difficultés c'était
compliqué oui c'est vrai je le reconnais
mais quand même ils s'en sont bien tirés
donc ce que nous disons nous c'est qu'il
faut que les distributeurs change de
logiciel
c'est plus je donne tel prix débrouillez
vous pour payer les agriculteurs c'est
on parle des coûts de production des
agriculteurs français parce qu'on impose
des règles de bien-être de sanitaires
d'environnement aux producteurs français
donc il ya des charges en plus plus
versé plus cher il faut que neuronaux
revenus soit
c'était positivement mais ça vous le
dites au président la république quant
au loyer vous l'avez vous écoute je lui
ai dit aussi directement que ça et je
lui ai dit ça ne marchera que si vous
mettez des gendarmes pour sanctionner
ceux qui grillent les feux rouges
mais nous nous tenons à une amélioration
oui ils veulent faire je pense qu'il va
le faire un tout cas julien de normandie
que nous avons rencontrés sur ce sujet
est en train de l'expertiser nous avons
d'autres experts avec lesquels nous
travaillons pour faire des propositions
mais on ne peut pas continuer ainsi
qu'est ce qui va se passer
tout le monde porte aux nues les
agriculteurs français mais si nous
sommes pressurisée comme ça par les
distributeurs
si nous avons des injonctions
contradictoires produisez mieux mais on
vous achètent moins cher les
agriculteurs continueront à faire
faillite
les industriels aussi on mangera encore
demain nos assiettes seront pleines de
produits importés est ce que c'est ça
qu'on veut donc il faut faire des beaux
reportages à la télévision pour monter
les agriculteurs et tout ce qu'ils font
les téléviseurs 2.0 3.0 4.0 qui font des
progrès considérables et je sais ce que
c'est dans une exploitation ce qu'ils
encourent en termes de temps de travail
d'investissement de formation et caetera
et à côté tant leur dîme et vos produits
chop chop qu'est ce qui est plus
important c'est le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs
non c'est les marges ce sont leurs
marges qu'ils défendent mais j'allais me
rendre sur les consommateurs aussi
apprécié à l'envers puisque vous en
parlez est ce que vous demandez aussi ce
matin un effort aux consommateurs alors
on sait que les temps sont difficiles
pour beaucoup de français mais est ce
que vous dites aux consommateurs il faut
accepter payer un petit peu plus cher
pour que nos agriculteurs soient
correctement rémunérés écouter ils l'ont
fait pendant le confinement dans leurs
modes d'achat
quand on les rencontre et qu'on leur
explique combien ça coûte c'est à dire
que quand c'est un centime par yaourt
pour que le producteur soit payé
correctement
franchement à la fin de l'année ça fait
3 euros par français quand je parle de
la production des poules pondeuses les
poules mange beaucoup de blé le b
augmente de 40% la charge alimentaire
pour les poules et les poules c'est 65 %
de la dépense pour un producteur un
centime par aof
voilà ce que nous demandons les français
mangent 249 par an faites le compte
ça fait deux euros 40 franchement est-ce
que c'est insupportable pour avoir un
revenu pour les agriculteurs 6 c'est
comme ça qu'il faut le dire et les
consommateurs sont prêts à soutenir les
agriculteurs d'ailleurs ils le disent
toutes les enquêtes du credoc le disent
aussi est en fait les distributeurs
n'arrête pas de parler de promotion
promotion promotion pour attirer la
clientèle
mais on voit quand même que la vente de
bio augmente or c'est plus cher la vente
de produits régionaux
c'est qui le patron est la démonstration
s'il en est besoin que quand on explique
les choses aux français qu'il faut payer
un petit peu plus ses producteurs pour
qu'ils puissent vivre
les français sont prêts à le faire
l'essor de ces gilles patron est
vraiment l'illustration que les
consommateurs ont changé d'attitude donc
oui je leur lance un appel solennel
fervent attendu nous avons besoin que
les consommateurs soutiennent les
agriculteurs français nous de faire des
déclarations d'amour on adore ça nous
fait du bien mais franchement acheter
les produits français et sert le
patriotisme alimentaire c'est soutenir
aussi les emplois en france c'est
soutenir les emplois en france
savez vous que le secteur qui a le plus
eu de faillite dans l'industrie c'est
l'agroalimentaire parce que nous sommes
les plus précieux risée de tous les
industriels de 2 l'année dernière du
fait de la crise sanitaire ou un âne en
venant sur les trois dernières années
encore et sur la crise sanitaire est ce
que vous êtes en mesure de chiffrer en
fait l'impact de cette crise sur les
revenus des agriculteurs du monde
agricole est ce que vous avez des
données l'assumer y ait des impacts très
directe nous avons demandé des plans
d'accompagnement pour les secteurs qui
ont souffert pommes de terre mange pas
de frites à la maison parce que ça
embaume doute la maison les frites on
les mange au restaurant on mange moins
de viande de l'épave et les robes vestes
etc etc
manger du steak haché on mange moins de
poissons mangent moins d'agneau on mange
ou en loin de canard on a tous ses
produits en stock donc on a demandé des
plans d'accompagnement oui pour partie
mais qui sont pas encore payés aux
producteurs c'est très très très très
long donc ça dépasse le milliard d'euros
et à cela vous ajoutez la taxation des
vins et des alcools par donald trump qui
taxent à 25% les alcools depuis le mois
de décembre
mais ça fait un an et demi qu'ils les
taxes c'est un milliard d'euros de
perdus à cause de ces taxations là donc
si l'agriculture va mal en ce moment
dans certains secteurs c'est aussi parce
qu'il a dû renoncer c'est là toute
l'agriculture
mais la fermeture des restaurants le
report sur les actions ciblées elles
vont là où il ya des besoins ou alors
ils vont là où il ya des besoins mais
elle met longtemps à arriver
et puis autre chose quand même il ya un
marché dont tôt sur lequel on n'a pas
apprise c'est le marché international
quand la chine arrêtent d'acheter du blé
etc le blé s'effrondre du soja et que
les belles les protéines s'effondre
quand la chine arrêtent d'acheter du
port le prix du porc passe de 1
euros 50 1 heure 20 quand il ya une
maladie de l'autre côté en allemagne
avec la fièvre porcine africaine les
courses et fanta il ya énormément de
facteurs qui impactent les cours
débouchés intérieur c'est vrai que ce
sont plutôt les distributeurs qui sont
nos interlocuteurs aujourd'hui parce que
les restaurants sont fermés marché
international pour tous les produits
d'exportation c'est plus sage
géopolitique des productions réussite
par exemple sur les marchés
internationaux les échanges à
l'angleterre il ya eu un impact très
fort nos exportations à la une le glycol
vers le royaume uni a eu des
acquisitions de précaution puisque comme
on est le produit qu'on exporte le plus
vers le royaume uni c'est le vin et les
alcools dont tous les anglais sont venus
faire leurs stocks rempli leur rôle de
partenaire un ami r31 meilleur
transworld positive sur ce sujet le
deuxième sujet c'est sont les produits
laitiers 800 millions et le troisième
secteur ce sont les fruits et légumes
bio sont moins on en royaume uni que
chez nous nous nous réjouissons de la
conclusion de la négociation de michel
barnier qui permet d'avoir ni taxes ni
quota choses sont excités il va y avoir
des complexités par rapport aux aspects
sanitaires et au contrôle donc des
ralentissements aux frontières des
certificats qui peine à arriver
les administrations sont longues et
lourdes bien sûr pour elle pour exporter
ou réexporter certains produits vers
l'angleterre il ya aujourd'hui des
délais d'attentes de 10o pour avoir un
papier un document attestant que c'est
conforme sur les produits frais 10 jours
c'est mission impossible
donc il y aura des complexités misrati
vont nous nous souhaitons garder le
débouché est par contre ce sur quoi nous
sommes vigilants
il ne faut pas que le royaume uni soit
une plateforme d'atterrissage des
produits venant d'ailleurs états unis
notamment qui drague énormément et le
royaume uni en semant pour amener les
produits américains qui ensuite
viendrait en europe
donc ça serait un hub ça serait un peu
singapour sur tamise si on peut dire
et ça nous n'en voulons pas donc il ya
plusieurs points de vigilance mais comme
c'est un débouché très important nous
exportons deux fois plus vers le
royaume-uni qu'ils exportent vers
l'union européenne
donc nous tenons à ce débouché et les
anglais aiment les produits français
donc on a envie de continuer à commercer
avec eux un mot puisque vous parliez des
différents aléas de la grippe aviaire
on en est aujourd'hui de la grippe
aviaire est ce que vous dites que la
filière est en danger alors la filière
et une secousse énorme et c'est pas la
première année il y a eu un
un virus extrêmement contagieux qui
s'est propagé à vive allure
il a fallu entre noël et le premier dans
pour rendre des décisions extrêmement
difficile de changer la façon de
contenir l'expansion cirque au lieu
d'abattre au fur et à mesure 3 km et
revenir pour stopper la propagation
analyse agriculteurs ont été à lui
c'était la bonne stratégie et les
agriculteurs ont été courageux et les
faits mais fédération le cifog centre
interprofessionnel du foie gras la
confirmation des aviculteurs ont joué le
jeu et ont vraiment travaillé beaucoup à
battre des milliers d'animaux à cette
période-là de noël canard abattu trois
millions de volatiles en tout et là nous
travaillons maintenant sur le plan
d'indemnisation ce qui est préoccupant
et c'est bien là tout le paradoxe par
rapport à d'autres débats nationaux
c'est que comment la contamination s'est
faite par les oiseaux migrateurs les
oiseaux migrateurs ont des courants de
migration ils passent toujours au même
endroit c'est toujours le même couloir
de migration
on sait qu'ils passent à tel moment qui
survole les zones à tel moment
et donc si les animaux sont dehors il ya
plus de risque qu'ils soient contaminés
donc il faut pouvoir rentrer klaus
serait tous les animaux c'est un peu
leur confinement eux quand il y a ces
passages d'oiseaux migrateurs et c'est
là où certains disent élevage plein air
il valait plus plein air rappelez vous
la loi villani qui voulait mettre tous
les animaux en plein air et tous les
élevages dehors ça serait une
catastrophe totale
donc je pense qu'il faut il tenir compte
de ces réalités sanitaires les éleveurs
et tous les partenaires du secteur ont
été très courageux de soutenir la
nécessité des battages par contre
immédiatement ils sont en train de poser
des règles pour l'année prochaine en se
disant puisque de toute façon les
oiseaux continueront à passer prenant
des règles draconiennes aujourd'hui de
claustration total sans dérogation
contrairement à ce qui avait été fait
par le gouvernement précédent qui a
aujourd'hui cause des problèmes que l'on
connaît
on va terminer avec un autre maire écolo
qui a pris une autre décision c'était
l'école le maire de grenoble qui a pris
hier un nouvel arrêté anti pesticides
dans sa ville pour interdire les
produits phytosanitaires
c'est la suite de l'arrêté qu'il avait
pris précédemment et qui risquait d'être
suspendu par le conseil d'état la il a
un petit peu changé les termes pour
éviter toute suspension par le conseil
d'état qu'est ce que vous pensez de cet
arrêté
j'ai hâte que la la guerre pour la
primaire chez europe écologie verts se
termine voilà j'ai hâte que la course à
l'échalote et celle de pérou keiko bons
voeux se termine parce que chacun y va
de son couplet une fois c'est jadot une
fois ses bayous une fois ses épaules
c'est bon quoi tous les arrêtés anti
pesticides pris par les maires ont été
cassées la première fois là il trouve un
angle d'attaqué de nouveau j'ai fait
faire une expertise juridique par les
services de la fnsea
quand le premier cas a été fait en loire
atlantique c'est pas des déchets qui
dérivent vers l'extérieur donc je pense
que ça ne tiendra pas mais cet
acharnement des écologistes sur le sujet
et malsain alors que nous sommes au
travail et que nous sommes dans une
posture de progrès et de dialogue révolu
comme de l'acharnement
c'est de l'acharnement c'est de
l'acharnement c'est une s'étonne
acharnement c'est vendre le grand soir
tous les matins s'est recueilli 10 on
peut fonctionner sans pesticides c'est
faux même en agriculture biologique nos
collègues utilisent les produits
phytosanitaires utilise la bouillie
bordelaise du cuivre etc
c'est ce sale arrêté est ce que vous
pensez qu'on peut avoir une france sans
pesticides la réponse est non
c'est comme si on disait on aura une
france sans médicaments la réponse est
non
quand vous êtes malade vous soigner
d'abord de l'homéopathie un petit cachet
d'aspirine et puis quand ça va moins
bien on va chez le médecin c'est pareil
pour les plantes
thériault une attaque on regarde on
observe si c'est pas grave on
n'intervient pas quand ça devient trop
grave et que saab et la culture en péril
on intervient et on en a besoin
sinon qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya des
résidus de mycotoxines dans les blés ou
dans les cultures et c'est mauvais pour
la santé
moi mais mes truie qui mange le blé de
notre exploitation si la fusariose qui
est une maladie du blé il ya ensuite des
mycotoxines dans la farine
ça fait avorter les truies pensez vous
que ce soit bon pour la santé des
humains quand on constate ça sur nos
animaux la réponse est non
donc sauf sur ce sujet nous sommes au
travail - 15 % produits phyto les plus
toxiques l'année dernière
à -9% sur la deuxième catégorie + 13 %
d'avis culture biologique qui regardent
les progrès au lieu de toujours dire
plus vite plus haut plus fort sans payer
plus cher merci beaucoup merci
christiane lambert date venu nous voir
bien spéciale agriculture demain on
recevra julien de normandie à votre
place pour une émission spéciale
agriculture merci stéphane pour regarder
une de ouest france qui consacre aux
agriculteurs en plus ça tombe bien ces
agriculteurs sans cesse contraints de
s'adapter cette lan vo ans marie bon
kick au fait qu'on fasse ce titre au
club et à la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
[Musique]